be rush absolutely coming in it's - he's
the only one in there and he's got an MP
9 he's gonna get flashed in he's good
guys this week on best of a2k is just
not enough a 3k not even close
we're not even gonna settle for a 4k
this week on Vesta we want the full 5 we
want the ACE this week we're going to
give you the best pistol aces the best
ace clutches and all the Aces in between
but first there's something we got to
get out of the way I'm talking about the
most legendary ace plays in
counter-strike Canon the kind of plays
that if you're new to the game are
required viewing and if you're already a
csgo guy or gal and you've seen them a
million times
well it's time to watch them a million
and one cuz there's that damn good they
will once again just be a hiko we've got
three from behind quad can he find a
fourth he could support he's our top mid
end all the way over toward atrium taps
and goes quite cold zeros quicker gets a
second as well as the ball will go down
and follows it up they're all lining up
gold there with the day basically Titan
changing things up they're gonna flash
their way through the smoke and now it's
gonna come down to shock see he's gonna
get caught in the corner god mouses by
it's gonna be torn away from them very
very quickly
oh my god - as well Nico he's on fire
we'll just do something else in the next
round if we're limited on money whatever
and there you go who's got the you go
right through the smoke as long as we
try to stay cool they're gonna be fine
what a sick thought oh my god JW he gets
the second one
he's looking for the ace he's got just
seven bullets and he's gonna go for it
in the corner now it's a one on one
emissions best shot is 25 seconds left
and he's got six health and he's gonna
go with us he said sprays here existent
trapped in the corner now 20 seconds the
bushes from Titan have been
what are we witnessing now near the last
one left
the one on four Dignitas the signing it
is not over yet they want a fight and
they want to continue to battle neo very
nearly lost the second world through the
wall and now with this smoke you can get
the bomb planted they have two smokes
left and that's a really big chrome
video because yes I Molotov and I bet he
would love to use the debye time but
they've already smoked down the form
there's another headshot coming through
he'd have to go over the edge touch into
winning the semi-finals here looking for
another spray a fight between sip NYX
and Penny it's all on sip he's alone he
gets one the bomb is right in front of
him he's clicking through the smoke and
missing the last couple of shots body is
on it with the defuse kid he's gonna get
one kill sip for this bro oh my god he
picks it up for now running back in he's
got the qualities looking for the ACE no
more bullets though are you kidding me
can't somebody peak on envious side and
well that's what happens when you go
around the corner happy with juan deag
debris is like sweating bullets guys I
feel like those legendary plays aged
like a fine wine
or like me oh are you doing are you
gonna throw up no why are you gagging oh
because D that triggers my gag reflex
too well anyways the next category is
ace clutches you already know a clutch
can change the course of an entire map
but an ace clutch well that's some
next-level [ __ ] the man who I thought
was gonna go for the contact way is
suddenly the last alive this is a done
round Guardian nowis question as to
whether he'll save Gator VP good
flashbang could get a couple more out of
this one I'm starting to crumble what's
going on one player has found three
kills Guardian look into Asus one now
this could be one of the best rounds of
the entire tournament so far four kills
picked up is down the crimped this was a
five buses one map and Cyndi arey could
be a factor because if he puts it in
front of Guardian how does he work back
in it's gone toward the dumpster that
means Guardian knows exactly why he's
God oh he's finally changed it as well
he's played that front position so often
and it's been a problem to Bri get
raided him by the wrong Molotov not his
teammate 30 seconds remaining still
possible though players like fer can
shut these situations down very quickly
the mages should confirm around this
point is Tarek oh my goodness funny all
the headshots surely he doesn't have a
chance he'll go for the plant it's
actually looking possible he'll get it
down here device is low and he has to
wait for his teammate he's gotta start
moving no because he doesn't have
information behind him he's expecting it
to be from the stairs but now that flash
comes out device trying to work back in
is giving away the fact that it become
the front
[Applause]
dc2 disappointing for the rotation to
come in pit the loss we're standing here
jumping Pete's 50 politic must be done
if you can get second killed after
father's walk and now you've got
position here
already pushing forward to try and find
them get the both in his sights minish
is only one JD I'm looking that correct
direction but it's a one versus four AWP
push out good shot JD after another he's
got this down to one versus two over
commitment and perhaps a little bit
zealous to try it early end this from
JDM it's just rain left alive he's gonna
find the quick kill on to happy but he's
got kioshima to contend with what a frag
they're coming in from rain we can't
make the approach to the bombs night he
does have some time is why he's gonna
try to get the frag onto the flanking
play the game sense from this man is
unreal there's still two more players to
find though
Grady's gonna get another one it's gonna
try to trick his opponent right now apex
oh oh my goodness oh this is this is
quite a turnaround no-one's dying Valdez
now he gets way out there he's gonna
take down breeze what else be fine oh
man he's just so good isn't he time to
play with
he can't go lower as well so smart bow
they he is waiting for sir c'mon all the
way around they want to make sure they
do not throw this one away this is a 1 B
5 here for Val they're looking for the a
squatch that bomb takes further and
further closer to detonation valve it
with another P kick I know the head shot
from foul day he's perfect so far one
more player to go he hasn't taken any
damage my god Valley is an absolute God
looking for something they start to go
their way and envious we'll just put a
cork on it
shut it down like a nice aged wine as
our pinky Kay's gonna get down though
and finds two engagements and he's aware
there's another player in pit
all of a sudden NBK not three quick
frags and now the palm is safe enough
from to pick it up he picks engagement
and BK and Dupree a space for the moment
there's one kill he's gonna go for
that's the ball back and forth
conventionally they had to shut it great
hold from a stall great job isn't it 30
seconds again for a one versus for
another one pillow tapping away and take
it down 25 seconds
he is looking for the straight ace touch
trying to get back in this game that
would be a bit of a miracle once again
he's picked up the palm and he wants to
talk stairs make it a bit of noise you
can shoot them out and just be as noisy
as possible
maybe they're gonna be looking the wrong
way but they're hiding in the corner now
it's a one-on-one makers coming in he's
just out of the palm forest
he needs one more kill will be historic
clutch if he could do it
Bernie landing on top is down to 50 ah
who doesn't love a good ace clutch now
up next are some plays that are equally
improbable the pistol ace if you get an
ace in the pistol round well that's
pretty damn good if you get an ace with
a pistol against a bye
well that's just spicy and soos look at
that running and gunning takes down JW
and all of my static line in Armour it's
really really good combination but
unless they fight in one of the time all
my Connor they will Souza's very low
seized although all my god he gets
another Killian now clocks running out
seven seconds all of us looking for the
kill by it goes and now OAC double
trouble that's criminal
pazi's left in unreal down in CT wants
to try and get more go by KZ some may be
off the thread a couple of headshots
easy to do just that is actually the
third burning at this round in the favor
of renegades with three beautiful one
times making a four unreal plays by
nexor is he gonna get the ACE gaseous
multipass undertow our sensor it's
actually something go there for me out
all right
mystic let's get in it off right around
the corner here from Maine and look at
that coming out of the doorway it's
gonna be screwed going down shock oh my
god Schatzi gonna be picking out what
not headshot I can't believe it is
looking for the ACE here all on this
home Connor on the other side let's see
if are you kidding me that's gonna be
the ace in the round on real play
dennis is extremely good on these
pistols to start that momentum our fast
play q point all three kills again I'm
done don't even buy guns just this guy
could use the USB for the entire game
and I would be convinced because g2 is
certainly has to be convinced he by me
perfect round time full of terror is
pushing his angles whereas all of my
stuff up the back Oscar knows yet fell
on the silicon get too close for Niko
just not missing a thing five versus
three now all right don't disbelieve
Jones mr. nappa babe he's going for it
boys he's going for the yeas Paul kills
to his name groups well guys we've seen
the most legendary ace plays in cs:go
history we've seen the best pistol aces
and the best ace clutches and if your
favorite ace isn't on this video yet
hold on there's one more section to go
here's what we're calling the best of
the rest of csgo aces Kerrigan he can't
reposition he has the frag he asked a
frag and he gets only one Tarek brave
enough to just hold the bombs lon the
nose guard is in construction trying to
back off trying to reposition season
tags in but doesn't fraggin holding the
angle once again but there's ago I does
he go low
it is a dance and now they concede
multiple ankle carry going take Soloff I
sit down Guardian on 11 HP reigns peaks
and he gets the angle now superior angle
is there a diffuse for the CT side the
nine edges yet they're spamming the
grenades they're touching the pod and
now go frame another pod that is trying
to defuse a again but no it's round
soneul over here special Guardian racing
for
they come nades rain in here come the
parties as well got in just put one down
they find a second you better believe he
can exactly that they've got to try and
compensate for giving liquid so much
room it's time to analyse that accuracy
is so good that they will fall trying to
pull back into the catwalk position he
stepped up in Cologne and he's doing
with palm down twist shouldn't go far
from this position knowing he's got to
save it and here it goes
here comes the hit yeah that's what my
machine help them with Oh Rob's it a
great call to sprays in head shots in a
row unbelievable and that's gonna be
over time look at Oscar just laughing so
covers corner no one above it bounced
smoke will cover the cat instead JDM
good contact play with the awp clear
squad but they still have to wait do
with the faculty the ball he's gonna go
for Scotty's got everyone in front of
them turns down take down two in fact
they're all lined up anything at all
make it an eight let's try and hold off
the rotations Oscar's go on Chris isn't
OP still in the picture off still very
much in the round oh please miss out
three it's down to it oh my god
he was absolutely coming in it's too
he's the only one in there and he's got
an MP 9 he's gonna get flashed in he's
good
oh my god stay away they started picking
you know a map-like trade over this at
times this nickname
Cory kills that is so beautiful
[Applause]
well guys that's all we got for you on
best of this week now if you could
kindly hit that you to base I'd really
appreciate it
that means headshotting the subscribe
button flicking over to the like button
hitting the comment section downloading
that guy who commented first and of
course watching our next video see you
next week thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]